in this segment we revisit the concept
of conditional expectation and view it
as an abstract object of a special kind
to get going let us start with something
simple the concept of a function let's
say a function H that map's real numbers
to real numbers as a concrete instance
consider the quadratic function that
map's
a number X to its square consider now a
random variable capital X what do we
mean when we write H of X for age
defined for example in this particular
way as the quadratic function H of X is
defined to be a random variable with
random variable it is the random
variable that takes the value little X
square
whenever capital X the random variable
happens to take the value little X and
this is the random variable that we
usually denote as the random variable x
squared now let us come to conditional
expectations the conditional expectation
of a discrete random variable is defined
by this formula it is like the ordinary
expectation except that we now live in a
conditional universe in which the random
variable capital Y is known to have
taken a value little Y and therefore
instead of using the ordinary formula
for expectations that involve the PMF of
X we now use that formula but with the
conditional PMF of X which is the
appropriate PMF that applies to this
conditional universe and if it happens
that the random variable capital X is
continuous we would have an alternative
formula but of the same kind where the
summation is replaced by an integral and
the PMF is replaced by a PDF now let us
look at this quantity here we have fixed
some particular little Y calculate this
quantity and what we get is a number it
is a number but the value of that number
depends on the choice of little Y if I
give you a different little wire
then you will get another number for
this conditional expectation this means
that this quantity here is really a
function of little Y and let us give a
name to this function let us call this
function G now that we have defined G we
can ask what is this object it's a
function of capital y it's a function of
a random variable so it should be a
random variable by itself by analogy
with the earlier concrete example it is
the random variable that takes the
numerical value G of little why whenever
capital y happens to take the value
little Y but G of little Y has been
defined to be the same as this
conditional expectation so it's the
random variable whose value is this
conditional expectation which is a
particular number if capital y happens
to take the value little Y this
particular random variable that we have
defined here G of capital y
we call it the abstract conditional
expectation of the random variable X
given the random variable Y to summarize
this notation here stands for a random
variable it is the random variable whose
numerical value turns out to be this one
if the value of the random variable
capital Y happens to be little Y it is a
function of capital Y once we know the
value of capital y then the value of the
conditional expectation is well-defined
it is known and it's equal to this
particular number it is of course a
random variable and as a random variable
it has all the attributes that random
variables have for example it has a
distribution that is a PMF or a PDF it
has a mean of its own and it has a
variance of its own so what will be next
in our agenda is to talk about these
attributes of this special random
variable
and also to use it in several examples